good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday
we're getting really close to the
weekend so close
you can almost taste it i can
you can smell it oh you smell it coming
on in
smell-o-vision nice nice
nice well it's a beautiful thing that's
thursday really like
we're about to head into another weekend
i actually have such a busy weekend
you do yeah because i have a wedding
this weekend so do you
and i'm a bridesmaid so i just have
wedding festivities all over again
wedding duties you know you have duties
i have a lot of duties big brown
duties you didn't have to say brown
it could have just been big duties
yellow duties no like just because
they're duties
yeah yeah yeah i just wanted to really
hone in on the fact that i was referring
to duty as in poop not judy as in job
and i was
referring to judy with a t and i'm
always referring to duty with a d
and that's just the difference between
us into the toilet out the sewer into
all that gross manure see the water
spinning round
then i slam the lid back down my duty
brown
my duty brown my duty brown my duty
brown that was a nice note you hit on
due date
it kind of was it was kind of like
sickening yeah
um also this would be a good time for me
to tell everyone that i'm going
to be out next week i am going on
vacation but i will be like
remote working so a few episodes will be
audio only with me some will be in the
studio with claudia oh they will
guest co-host yeah i thought did i say
that yeah you guys said that
you just farted um it'll be really touch
and go because i totally forgot that i
had offered to do that
and i had made no plans regardless
there's going to be five shows next week
it's just gonna be
you know some audio perhaps some in
studio maybe i'll do one by myself
you tried that one it's so hard yeah
that if you're ever wondering like why
we don't do that claudia tried it once
at the breath in my defense like
we were new to podcasting i feel like
now i could podcast in my sleep like i
might be able to do it better but i
don't even know if i want to give it a
shot
where would i sit like you know right
here literally on the table
so i don't know it just would feel weird
maybe you could give it another go i'm
down because i actually feel like that's
a really good i'm always trying to like
hone my skills you know in comedy
podcasting hosting
and i think that's actually a really
good um skill to have to be able to host
a podcast alone there are very few
people who do it
without consistent guest slash co-host
and it's very impressive and there are
very few people who do it
live like our show isn't streamed live
anymore but it's still live like it's
stream of conscious we don't edit or
like have
segments or anything we sit here for one
hour record it and post it right but if
you were to do
you know i'm gonna record 15 minutes
here by myself and then the next segment
like that does make it
that's true more doable i'll think about
it
yeah i mean that would be hysterical if
you tried it i know
a little scary really scary um
really really what if you take a sip of
water what if i have to like pee
i don't know i mean that would happen on
this show too i know i always think
about that how like honestly i went on
tour for two years and i didn't sneeze
on stage
once your body just knows yeah except i
did have diarrhea before my show in
houston but that was really my fault it
was the whataburger
i take full responsibility for my
actions yes you should
you take full responsibility for
bringing up duty thrice now on the show
it's not even been
three minutes duty i did it for oh can
we talk about my shirt
can we please so a lot of people there
was outrage from the community
rightfully so
right thank you community i didn't even
realize until you guys said something on
my behalf and i was just like
yeah on tuesday you gave me the shirt i
said i was gonna wear it the next day
but as we spoke about yesterday i had a
lunch meeting yesterday
and i was not showing up to the regency
in this shirt i'm sorry so i had to wear
like a nice don't apologize to me
apologize to logan
sorry logan so i wore it today i was
really excited to wear it i have to say
this is her maverick athletic shirt yes
for those who can't see or are listening
as a podcast
i have to say like we are fully immersed
in the merchandising industry like we
look at constant
samples this shirt is so comfortable
like i have we've got to get this exact
prototype
for our next drop it's like stretchy but
like fitted at the same time it's like a
fabulous material you know i have like
three shirts i wear in rotation that
pink one that has all the rips in it
intentionally that uh arkansas won we
know
arkansas so i do believe this is going
to be thrown into the rotation it's so
comfortable and it's black so i can't
get stained
i'm so happy to hear that it's the gift
that keeps on giving yeah i'm so
appreciative thank you so much for this
wonderful
thoughtful and generous gift you're so
welcome now i saw someone commented
yesterday now i have to get you a leash
with them
you do with the contraption you do i'll
talk to zach because he made ours so he
maybe he can make you one too
he made it it was two things put
together that he just sort of like
contrapted oh interesting crafty over at
the wine reb house he's such a macgyver
stop he's such a belle's dad no
belle belle is an innovator maurice was
just an agitator it's just a deadbeat
dad
um we have a great show for you guys
today the real housewives of beverly
hills was on last night we finally got
to the entree we got meat and potatoes
we did and i really need to talk through
how i'm feeling because i don't know how
i'm feeling and
maybe how you're feeling can shed light
on how i'm feeling
okay because you're still you're you're
you're not buying it i don't want to
spoil the tv recap because it's at the
end of the show but uh
um and i'll tell you what that's a
little taste i
of whether or not you're buying it i got
my credit card out and i bought it like
i
fully purchased whatever jane was
selling wow
okay it was very emotional i don't know
how you could watch that and not i know
i think she was innocent
i was looking on twitter after an ever
almost like crocodile tears wore
intentionally worn non-waterproof
mascara to film herself crying even
though she's been
in theater for her whole life and she
really knew she was like so feeling so
emotional she obviously would have worn
waterproof mascara can i tell you i did
think something similar about the
mascara i was like
it's just like a lot of black makeup
coming down your face when like you
probably knew you were gonna cry
i had similar thoughts about the mascara
yeah me too
okay cool thank you for that taste yes
well we're gonna dive into it but before
we do that we wanted to let you guys
know that yesterday jackie and i spent
the afternoon
recording a very fabulous podcast
episode for our patreon channel
which is an exclusive deer toaster so we
do to your toasters once a week and a
lot of people are like claudia jackie
that ain't enough and we hear you so we
dedicated an entire 50-minute episode
to deer toasters we got some really
interesting submissions
of things we've never spoken about just
like interesting pickles people have
found themselves in
um we get into religion we get into
in-laws oh my god
the in-law stuff i was laughing so hard
yesterday because
no i was dying at the mlm oh the ml but
being so funny when there was a question
about like what you should call
your in-laws like this woman has been
dating her fiance for 10 years and
just kind of waits till she makes eye
contact with her in-laws in order to
address them because she doesn't want to
call them by their first name she
doesn't want to call them mr and mrs
um and then there's this whole thread
yes and so so dark that like
everyone does this i was cracking the
fact that like i thought this girl was
unique in her situation
when the episode came out somebody
started a thread in the facebook group
for all the patreon members called toast
after dog you can only get it if you
become a member
and every single person was like i
literally have never referred to my
in-laws as anything i just wait for them
to address me it's the most shocking
thing
it's hysterical someone's like once you
have kids then you can call them like
grandma and grandpa she's like i should
have had kids sooner
literally guys it's such a funny episode
it's available on our patreon
patreon.com toast for 7.99
per month you can get five extra
episodes from us at their vlogs like we
just vlogged my birthday
we've vlogged so many of our trips the
great chile cook-off and we also do
podcast episodes we do podcast episodes
general q and a's we do dear toaster
submissions we do toast radio which
isn't
always it's a controversial segment but
we've stopped doing it toast radio has
been deceased now for about two years i
saw somebody requested in the facebook
group yesterday
ask a new shower receipt so yeah there's
just tons of good stuff it's a great way
to support the podcast and get more
content for days when you're just like
really chugging along to five o'clock
yeah for sure
for sure okay now i guess without
further ado
where are you right here being perfect
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
helium 10. imagine the freedom of being
your own boss and running a business
that best suits your lifestyle and
schedule
helium 10 wants to tell you how to
embark on a smart career where you call
the shots
starting your own amazon business is a
great way to do that it's the best way
to work from home and be your own boss
amazon isn't just an online superstore
it's actually a marketplace that
connects amazon buyers and amazon
sellers
anyone can become a seller thanks to
fulfillment by amazon
and to helium 10 software and with
fulfillment by amazon amazon handles the
complicated and expensive parts of
running a business
like receiving inventory warehouse
storage shipping and even returns
over half the products sold on amazon
are by everyday normal folks using
fulfillment by amazon
helium10 is an all-in-one software suite
designed to help people just like you
launch build and manage a profitable
business on amazon
helium10 is like a business in a box it
has all the tools and training to guide
you to your journey of financial and
personal independence
there's no invention or big idea
required helium 10 will find you the
right product to sell
and handle so many other aspects of your
business plus the startup cost for
launching a business on amazon is much
smaller than you think a fraction of
what other ventures might require
helium 10 has been used by over a
million people worldwide and they
collectively account for roughly 4
billion
in e-commerce sales per month so get in
there get your coin
you've got free time you want to just
make some money on the interwebs
check it out work when you want and from
wherever you want
take whenever take advantage of this
incredible offer from helium 10
getting 50 off your first month of the
helium 10 platinum account
when you go to helium10.com toast
that's h-e-l-i-u-m-10.com
toast don't wait to get that 50 off your
first month go to helium10.com
slash you guessed it toast thank you for
that
first up is a little free britney news
britney spears has a big win in her
conservatorship case as
judge allows her to hire her own
attorney britney spears is getting new
representation during a court hearing
wednesday judge brenda penny
approves spear's request to hire her own
lawyer in her conservatorship case
following the resignation of her court
appoint appointed attorney
spears was also granted permission she's
crazy that's brittany was
using a court appointed attorney for the
last however many years
yeah she was also granting permission to
hire matthew rosengart whose firm has
represented the likes of steven
spielberg sean penn
ben affleck and eddie vetter i'm so glad
ben affleck's
lawyer is working with brittany i just
have to say i'm sure this guy matthew
was great but there's truly only one
person for the job and that's l woods
oh you really think so 100 maybe that's
what legally bond three will be about
yes i'd love that that's actually a
really good concept it is i think they
probably already started filming but you
know it's never too late to switch it up
never no one has compassion like l no
one and nobody really understands the
ins and outs of the legal system
and the use of legal jargon quite like l
woods no and nobody understands
sisterhood like
screw sisterhood totally
i think it's actually a great match i
think so too i hope this lawyer can do
justice for brittany i mean this is like
such a
it's a win but it's like relatively
small win yeah
very small because i do feel like
there's still so much corruption in
whatever this court case is this corner
appointed lawyer the judge
i just feel like everyone's being paid
off so like she can fight her hardest
but at the end of the day
i just feel like the odds are against
her well i had
also heard that like she had a court
appointed attorney to begin with because
she could have easily hired an attorney
who would have taken advantage of the
situation because like she's in a
conservatorship and like there's
like they did that trying to protect her
like here's a court appointed attorney
who has no
you know stake in the matter and that
obviously wasn't
working out for her but i think that
that was the original intention it
wasn't to like
not give her representation it was to
make sure that like she didn't get taken
advantage by a big law firm
right that sees this case that's like
the majority keys like girardi keys
yeah yeah you guys gerard case i don't
know how i'm gonna just not talk about
it no i know the end of the show you
know what they say
that famous proverb is so true all roads
lead to gerardi keys
yeah it's really and what who is keys
i don't know right in a law firm it's
like allen allen and allen you know like
those are people so keith is probably a
person probably a person going to jail
not a good person are you ready for our
next story and couples looking miserable
in public news
my absolute favorite type of news to
report on because
who can relate more than me haley bieber
blasts beyond false rumors surrounding
las vegas incident involving
justin what happens in vegas stays in
vegas but not if you're one of
entertainment's hottest couples
taking to instagram stories on wednesday
hayley bieber shut down rumors about an
alleged
incident that went down in sin city
between her and justin
she said reminiscing on how amazing last
weekend was had the best time surrounded
by so much love
and then she said any other narrative
floating around is beyond false
don't feed into the negative [ __ ]
peeps peace sign right so he had a
concert in vegas and
after the concert they were walking
through the casino people were filming
them
and somebody caught them like rounding a
corner where he appeared to be yelling
at
haley she's very calm and he's like all
hyped up talking about something
we have literally no idea what he's
talking about but of course the jelena
fans
blew that video up and now everyone's
like he's yelling at her
like poor haley and honestly um as
someone who
is constantly you know yelling at your
spouse yeah um
it's really not that big of a deal and i
just feel like
this narrative being stirred up by the
gelena stands which i want to talk about
the juliana stands for what i didn't
know this was
the jelena stands doing i saw it on tick
tock first like two days ago before
normal people see it jelena like oh
really like
leave haley alone these gelena fans are
so toxic they are grown-ass people who
dedicate their lives
i actually can understand like a grown
person
spending a lot of their time energy in a
fandom like i like i do with taylor
swift like there's really nothing
not normal about that to me but to do
that for a couple that hasn't been
together in five years yeah maybe more
is beyond my genuine comprehension of
normal human behavior
and i think that we really need to get
these people evaluated who run these
jilina tiktok
accounts like you would die at the
content like it drives me up a wall it's
like
you are literally glamorizing one
something that we know to be such a
toxic behavior
at such a toxic relationship and we're
like bringing down haley so we could
bring this toxic couple back together
like i don't understand
the impetus behind it i really don't
yeah so
i'm so team haley it's disgusting yeah
me too i feel like we always get these
snippets and honestly anything without
context can be made to look like
something completely that isn't but we
always get these snippets of justin like
you know looking kind of miserable i've
seen like oh he won't hold her hand like
they got out of a car and she wanted to
hold his hand and he didn't like
sometimes i don't want my hand held like
this a lot of times i don't want my hand
held like if your
palms are clammy get them away if i'm
cold and your hand is cold
ooh don't touch me yeah like i'm very
sensitive about hand holding as well
i also in the video like he could be
yelling about any
number of things he just got off the
stage up he's swarmed by a mob you think
he's going to take
that time right a million people
watching let me yell at my wife
it's just so ridiculous and i actually
feel bad because i've somehow ended up
on like jelena tick tock
and there's so many videos that of
course like don't look great like yes
he you know gets out of the car when the
paparazzi are filming and he slams the
door in haley's face like
do i think he's trying to hurt haley no
which i think he's like self-centered
and didn't realize his wife was getting
out on the same side of the car yeah
like
i don't know i just feel because if it
were me in a relationship and
people were filming every little thing i
did you could find 30 000 things a day
that could be perceived as like ben
being mean to me or me being mean to man
like no it's just called being married
like let it go
yeah normalize married people having
conflict
in public on podcasts yeah and i think
the more public it is the healthier
i completely well it depends if it's all
hidden behind yeah yeah no totally it
just it's all
depends i just refuse to believe any
other narrative that haley and justin
are really in love
i know and they're a good strong couple
who have like a mutual faith and i just
really feel like
i refuse to believe anything else i
really do i was just looking at some of
their wedding photos it must have been
their anniversary or something
because all these photos uh were coming
up and i was actually thinking like it's
so crazy that they're like the biggest
couple in the world and they really had
such like a a normal wedding like you
know
like you know we're gonna invite all of
our friends in a church like it wasn't
crazy like he's beautiful like they're
just really a
traditional couple they are so
faith-based traditional couple
yeah so i i believe that they had a
wonderful weekend i actually think that
i was actually thinking like he was
everywhere this weekend in vegas
yeah and i feel like they had such a
great weekend in vegas no i know she's
like so supportive of his
dreams and i feel like justin bieber has
been and will continue to be one of the
biggest pop stars in the world but
they said that in scooter braun's
article like he can't tour
and i think hayley is like this
grounding force right that's what
scooter said that this tour is going to
be different because haley's there
right he like quit his tour mid what was
that album purpose
yeah so good um he like quit in the
middle because he like just couldn't do
it yeah
which i understand but now i feel like
we're going to see a whole new
era of justin bieber agreed looking
forward to it me too
are you ready for our next story it's a
little ice cream leave haley alone
sorry are you ready for our next story
yeah more ice cream now it's ice cream
news but it's good ice cream news thank
god i'm so done with this twisted ice
cream news from yesterday i'm still
vomiting me and jackie both walked in
and said we had the weirdest dreams last
night
and we think it's because of the
poisonous craft mac and cheese ice cream
we tried on air yesterday if you missed
it go check out yesterday's episode on
youtube and podcast app yeah but i've
been seeing that ice cream like
everywhere
like it's so good what's wrong with
everybody it tastes exactly what you
think it tastes like craft mac and
cheese frozen
why is that good are you interested in
that yeah why don't you just freeze your
mac and cheese
yeah literally make a sorbet for
yourself put it in a blender mix it up
and now you're in a blender okay but
some exciting ice cream news
tyra banks is launching an ice cream
company called smize cream
oh such a good name smize cream isn't
just an ice cream shop tyra banks hopes
her new ice cream company named after
her signature modeling expression of
smiling with your eyes
is the start of an empire with a reach
and scope akin
to disney she says walt disney is one of
my inspirations my
role models i look at what he did and
how it's still relevant to this day
his legacy lives on the family
entertainment the happiest place on
earth
that's what i want a legacy smize
comprises not only a collection of seven
ice cream flavors including the
best vanilla i ever had that's the name
of it cookie caramel queen and chocolate
barbecue
but also a cast of original animated
characters including dj splits and lil
y she said we're going to do movies and
cartoons we have a book proposal about
dj splits being the matriarch
of the family and her grandson lil y who
thinks he has magic but he doesn't
one day magic happens involving a
factory and ice cream and it changes the
fate of their lives
wow that's so sounds so good i'm not
understanding what's going on
okay she's launching an ice cream
company with you know a lot
and it's akin to disney well she has big
dreams for it just like you know walt
disney had big dreams
like i think she's just inspired by walt
disney
i don't think this means necessarily
there's going to be movies and parks but
it's just like i have a dream of
creating something really i kind of got
from this that there
will be there will be no but she's not
saying i want some ice cream to
model the walt disney company okay she's
saying like i want to
to be its own build something bigger
than myself like walt disney before me
got it and that name is great the name
is great i think it's a great start a
really cute concept of having like
characters yes and i just
love i mean little white thinks he has
magic but he doesn't no i mean the
campers are [ __ ]
quaking right the cameras are excited
about this news because they love ice
cream and they love tyra banks they do
she's a great role model for shippers is
a great role model for
people everywhere and campers who need
role models oh my god speaking of the
campers
watching last night porsha and kyle oh
devastating
devastating yeah devas well i mean once
again just once again all roads lead
back to tom gerardi keys
yes anyways um so that's some exciting
ice cream news i'm sure it's gonna be
delicious
and looking forward to seeing what else
comes of some ice cream empires yes me
as well i wish i had something else to
say
would you try this my ice cream yeah of
course she said it's the best video
she's ever had
that's the name of it what must be the
best vanilla she's ever had if that's
the name of it
yeah i'll try it for sure this is
actually good normal ice cream like
i mean i went on my whole rant earlier
in the week and i actually read a lot of
comments people did not agree with me
but i still don't care
um normalize not making ice cream fancy
like the shittier the better yeah this
looks like good old-fashioned oh that
does look delicious
yeah it's called that flavor strawberry
birthday cake
oh that sounds good my favorite ice
cream do you ever have you
thought of like what the best ice cream
you've ever had is
i'd have to think more i have to spend
more time but it also
it depends like where you are eating it
like it's like the experience as well
yes but i'm talking about just the ice
cream itself
i i couldn't tell you mine's gabel's do
you remember yeah but i think that's
where you are eating it like you're in
this like no old-fashioned you're on the
side of a highway
also we're like coming straight from fat
camber so we haven't had a real piece of
you know ice cream in a few months that
is a good call everything tastes better
when you're on you're in the pokemon
from fat camp yeah so there was this ice
cream place near fat camp
called gabel's it was like an old school
like shop like
burgers fries shakes and they have the
best if you're ever in the poconos go to
i think it's called gables kabels
whatever
the birthday cake ice cream it's like
literally has chunks of
vanilla like box cake in it it's so good
so like
when i think of the best ice cream i've
ever had i always think about that like
i would actually drive two hours today
just to go get it
that's i would go with you let's go it's
really not that long for the drive
we're never gonna do it add it to the
mukbang
are you ready for our next story only if
it's an x-ray that's brought you by
excuse me curology yes it is
did you used to think your skin goals
were unattainable jackie i know i
grew up with like such dry skin with so
many blackheads and i was like this is
just going to be my life forever
well thankfully we found curology
whether you're trying to take control of
acne or if acne is no longer your top
skin concern
fine lines dark spots occasional
breakouts clogged pores
curology will customize a prescription
formula with three active ingredients
picked for you to tackle your skin care
needs
so when i took their um like quiz and
quest filled out the questionnaire
i really highlighted how my skin is
super dry and like can be flaky but also
certain parts of my skin are so oily
it's like confusing yeah combination
that's what i learned that i have
and all these blackheads on my chin and
my nose that i just like assumed were
there forever
um i really liked how personalized the
questionnaire was because
literally everyone's skin is so
different so you get your treatment plan
you start by answering questions online
about your skin and sending in a couple
selfies to curology that was a dark
moment like seeing my skin in the
natural
yes no filter nothing then they'll match
you with a licensed dermatology provider
who gets to know your skin and if it's a
good fit you'll get a customized
prescription cream
to address your acne fine lines dark
spots and more then curology sets you up
with a personalized treatment plan and
ships your formula
which is custom right to your door so um
i got a cleanser i got a prescription
uh cream and i got a moisturizer and
it's just so simple i feel like
it's confusing sometimes like do i need
to use 50 skin care products or
five it's confusing so i feel like three
is the perfect amount i've definitely
noticed a huge change in my skin
especially when it comes to
the texture of my skin it's a lot more
healthy and and not
crusty almost which is like a gross way
to describe it um take control of your
acne dark spots breakouts or whatever
your unique concerns are with a powerful
skin care treatment made just for you
go to curology.com toast to unlock your
free 30-day trial again that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash toast for a free 30-day
trial and you can see curology.com for
all the details but
curology.com toast for that free 30-day
trial
great yeah no your skin is looking sick
and noticing on my instagram which is
nice that is nice
next story a little throwback news mtv
is bringing back hit
tv series cribs 20 years later oh i
think that's a wise decision
your favorite real estate show from
childhood is back mtv announced
wednesday it's revived its hit tv series
cribs more than 20 years since its debut
the show which gives an inside look at
various celebrities and their lifestyles
including a full tour of their homes
is set to return on august 11th
according to a press release
the upcoming season already has an
exciting lineup
whose homes we'll be seeing well i just
want to say before that
i think this is so great i think it took
them like a little too long with the
advent of like the youtube
home tour and how popular they are like
cribs could have been cashing in on this
for the last like
10 years yes and i'm pretty sure like a
year ago we announced cribs was coming
back and then you said that and now
did i yeah you said like they're behind
like we get youtube home tours of
everyone's houses and i will watch a
youtube home tour of literally any rich
person like it's so fascinating
it really is so here is who's on the
season so far and
i if rach parcell isn't on it then i
don't want it not even close
first ashley simpson and evan ross
didn't they have a reality show so don't
we know what their house looks like and
if we want to know like not to be mean
but like who cares
i agree i think hollywood like really
needs to stop trying to make like ashley
simpson and evan ross as a couple happen
like
we got the reality show it got canceled
like we're not interested we said no
thanks
yeah you know yeah big sean christian
siriano
cool johnny weir mm-hmm jojo siwa
yes even though like i've seen yeah like
we know every single crowd every
youtuber like comes in and like films
her house and she did a full-fledged
tour yeah jordan woods kathy griffin
marseille martin kathy griffin will be
interesting she's actually like a rich
celebrity
yeah martha stewart fabulous nick young
nico tortorello nick young does he play
for the lakers
i think so wow i think they call him
swaggy p if i'm
well yeah they do call him swaggy he
dated iggy azalea
he's like a really i think a good
basketball player so he's definitely
like rich and has like a nice house
love to see it snooki rick ross
nookie's interesting yeah yeah i mean
i'm
ryan lochte scott disick tia maori
tanasha tj lavin and others
okay not bad not great i also think
first of all if i was in charge of the
cribs
franchise i would do like multiple
digital series on like snapchat or
something because i really want to see
inside rach parcells house like
i think influencers people are obsessed
with influencers home tour like people
from the bachelor like
reality influencers generally give you a
home tour no everyone from the bachelor
has a home tour on youtube i would just
really like for them to not do it
exclusively in l.a like one of my
favorite um cribs is mariah carey's
penthouse in the city like yeah it's
interesting like of course big house is
in el air cool but i'd like to see a
ranch in wyoming a penthouse in
manhattan yeah
a sick condo beachfront in miami like i
really want to see
um a national cribs so i hope that they
do that i don't know if all those people
live in l.a a lot of them do i don't
know either maybe just for the first
season because they obviously probably
filmed during covet like they stuck to
one place
i feel like the cast like it's not
bad it's not great though and if you
think about who used to be on cribs like
this is a step down right harry mariah
carey simon cowell 50 cent hugh hefner
scooped
snoop dogg ozzy and sharon osbourne tony
hawk like
yeah they and they needed like three
marquee people to like market this
around like they needed
martha stewart could have been one of
those people yeah but they sort of like
buried her in there
yeah i don't think there's two other
people who are like big enough names
they need like martha stewart
they needed like a kardashian sorry yeah
and they needed like someone huge in
sports like a rod or whatever
yeah i i mean maybe this will be the
launching maybe they have to work their
way up again to like establish like that
people even care about chris
yeah um but i don't know i just feel
like it's another reboot that we're not
going to be hearing about
no and you know what i have come to
realize as an adult like when watching
cribs they showed us like four rooms in
the house
they never showed us like a true tour of
the house of course some of them were
really big so like it took
but they always showed us the kitchen
master bedroom and the outside and the
garage like yeah there are other parts
of the home
what does your laundry room look like
movie theater we would see yeah or like
a game room
but we never saw like the kids bedrooms
yeah like guest room yeah we never saw a
full home tour they were like really
they were 30 minute episodes and i think
there was
two people per episode so that's like 12
minutes and it's just not enough time
or maybe that's what made it good like
you never got bored you always wanted
more now i'm sure we'll be like is this
over yet
hmm that's a good call you know i'm good
on your mud room
no but like there is a true mud room
community yeah there is
but i don't know like but that's for
like the instagrams or
instagram people we'll see and i don't
know how popular mud rooms are in l.a
how much is it how does it run in there
no i think it's like popular everywhere
you know like to have like a room for
your you know umbrellas and stuff
no that's not what a mud room is for
it's like for like the kids backpacks
like you have like a little cubby like
you leave your shoes there
and mud and of course mud but like it's
more than just like a place for
when it rains you basically have to
leave all your [ __ ] there yeah yeah yeah
your dog leash your dog poop bags if you
have
a dog yeah okay our fifth and final
story is a twofer
a little real housewives news that'll
even lead into our tv recap how does
that sound
it's the final story
i couldn't hit what pitch you took us to
it's the final
story
[Music]
okay first up ramona singer is denying
being fired from roni
fans asked her on her instagram did you
get fired fans want to know and she
replied
quote nope yeah um i feel like since we
reported on this news and then we
watched the episode and there's been new
reports coming out like about the
reunion which we'll talk about
yeah um i'm more convinced than ever
that ramona's probably not getting fired
agreed
one because i don't think it would be
the proper remedy if ramona gets fired a
bunch of other people need to get fired
i don't think just firing ramona is
enough to salvage this
um show and
two yeah she said no so
yeah um there are i think like honestly
people at rooney
production are quaking because also page
six reported that the current season 13
reunion taping has been pushed back from
august 5th
until september amid a decline in
ratings and
why maybe like what would that have to
do
what would pushing the reunion back have
to do with declining ratings
just curious i don't know i feel like if
they were to film the reunion like right
now pretty much like really nothing's
happened like
off the show yeah and nothing and so
maybe they're waiting for more of the
season to play out to get more fan
reactions
so that they can talk about that at the
reunion there's literally nothing to say
there's nothing to say and filming on
the next season
is being delayed until early 2022 and
usually they start filming
at the end of the summer yes so honestly
i think this gives them a lot more time
to start looking for some new women and
i feel like actually if
casting wants to reach out to me i have
some good ideas like for people
like that are notable and people that i
know like i think that the show needs a
complete reboot would you dominate
yourself
i mean i have like literally one time
someone from
shed media which is the production
company reached out to me and they were
like hey are you doing like we want to
know do you have any people you would
recommend
and i just throw back yeah me never
heard back so i think if i ever get
reached out to again
i will give like an actual list of
people who i think would be down and who
have a lot of money and are interesting
and funny and like like to go out and
party
and would you still say and me like of
course it would be like a list of ten
people are you still interested
it would be a list of ten people claudia
ashrae so you're interested still
of course okay i know
logistically and just like
metaphysically
you cannot be on the real housewives of
new york if you have a podcast where you
talk about it it's just like a line that
can't be crossed for sure but like if
you
got the gig we would stop talking about
it of course you know yeah
so i think that's that's an easy solve
so i don't really um
know where what's going to happen all of
this information and by the way you were
right when you said that the reports by
ramona coming out
were on like a bunch of blogs and none
of it was on page six when there is
actual information
to be leaked about roni it goes straight
to page six like this reunion news so
yeah the ramona firing thing i'm
currently
not in believing agreed and then our
other piece of real housewives news is
that the real housewives of miami were
seen
filming with some new faces the cast was
spotted filming the upcoming peacock
series saturday during larsa pippin's
birthday party
at miami hot spot kiki on the river an
insider exclusively told page six
the events guest included miami alums
alexia marisol and adriana
my favorites as well as rumored new cast
members kiki barth nicole martin guerre
d
abrera and julia lemigova okay good i'm
glad they're like spicing it up while
also keeping like
adriana alexia marisol i can't believe
larson made the cut
i know so that's what i was going to say
um it does get first of all
did i make this up or is this a peacock
show this is the peacock show which is
also weird
very bizarre maybe if it's like good
enough it'll get on to bravo
um but i agree i think the the
legitimacy of the show is completely
destroyed with larsa like she's so and
first of all she never would have taken
the shot if she wasn't asked
from the kardashian crew of course and
like she's just kind of desperate now
and she just gives me like losery vibes
and i i'm afraid she'll bring those
vibes to the show which is a very toxic
environment the only thing i want to say
in lars's defense even though like i'm
totally team kardashian like she crossed
them she crossed me it's over i'm not
interested
the few times we did see her on
kardashians like she really has that
just that one trip
that one trip with sarah where she where
she was everyone was being nuts
roasted her yeah she has the attitude
and personality for a show for a
housewife and so
i feel like if you can separate her from
the kardashian drama
and i don't even remember her on season
one of real housewives of miami i don't
think i watched that season
i did and i literally don't remember her
but she was still married to scottie
pippen so she was like a really big deal
in miami
got it i think i came in at season two
and
she was gone because i don't remember
her at all i feel like
she could be i don't know i'm on the one
hand like on its face i'm not here for
it but then when i think about it more
i'm like if she brings that sarah howard
energy to the show like we've got a
great show
you know what's so funny is that real
housewives miami is like this
experimental kind of like guinea pig for
bravo remember when they did the
live reunion like an hour they went live
at our union it was so
absolutely insane and brilliant um and i
feel like they're always doing weird
things with this franchise just using it
as like a guinea pig like now they're
going to be on peacock like yeah
is anyone going to watch it we'll see
we'll see also very upsetting to see
that lisa hockstein
is not a part of it very upsetting and
you know the thing with larsa is that i
just feel like she's of a different
like i don't i can't see her jiving well
with like alexia marisol
i don't know the new girls but i just
feel like
larsa's very like instagram if that
makes sense yeah and the other women are
just like more like
adults yeah i i think that's possible
even though they might be like similar
ages because no one knows how old larsa
is but
maybe these new girls are like more
instrumental yeah and so it's like you
know
yeah that'll be well always looking for
more content so
thrilled about this yeah no it sounds
pretty good we got some emojis we got
some new people that's all we were
really asking for um oh and phil
collins's ex-wife is not on it was she
in that
i guess not yeah that was interesting
when like she was like not leaving his
house
because she like she didn't get in in
the divorce and she like refuses to
leave
it actually would have been interesting
but i'm sure they didn't want that
plastered everywhere
yeah so everything's looking good for
real housewives of miami now it's time
to talk about charity keys
gerardi keys the tv recap segment is
brought to you by something we're really
excited about love island
after a year of being cooped up at home
it's time to let loose take some risks
and live it up
no one does that better than the singles
on love island now streaming on
paramount plus
watch as the islanders head to hawaii
pair up and try not to get eliminated
while facing their ultimate temptation
with the return of casa amor and new
challenges that will test their
relationships and friendships
who's being genuine who's full of it you
decide what's going down and who goes
home with love
and cash plus don't miss love island
exclusives on paramount plus
including live hits behind the scenes
footage and extra episodes
it's shaping up to be a summer of
romance passion and lots of drama
watch the claws come out and the tears
flow with the new season of love island
now streaming on paramount plus head to
paramountplus.com
villa to try it for free and if you've
never watched some island i hadn't
either and it's so good and you don't
need to see
like old episodes you can just dive into
this new season because it's so good
it's so good definitely check it out
we're loving watching it and i'm so
excited for casa and more like i just
can't even tell you what we are in for
okay i want to talk about the real
housewives of beverly hills because i
felt like it was such a meaty episode
while also being
so boring if it weren't for the erika
scenes
there was so much terrible filler lisa
rinna on the phone showing her old
dresses in her like
hoarder's garage was truly a sad moment
for
society then lisa at sutton's house with
her daughter
also kappa kappa genius like so stupid
and boring
there was nobody i liked meeting
sutton's daughter by the way same
there was just so much filler boring
stuff in the episode and the only thing
that made it even remotely interesting
was of course all the drama with erica
we got her on zoom and i'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me what luck like
the day we find out i know that all of
this stuff is going down with the lion
air lawsuit is also the day everyone
gets coded and they all have to
quarantine and nobody has good enough
wi-fi to stream zoom like
that scene i feel like i got nothing i
couldn't decide whether she was being
genuine or not it was too blurry
i agree i felt like but it was it was
good enough like in order
like there was no you know smoking gun
there or anything and i and i think that
actually the visual
of her just like sitting in her new
house like um
played well for her narrative um
as opposed to like if she got together
with all the women and she's in a full
look and she's talking about
you know like it works out it worked out
kind of it wouldn't have looked good
it would not have looked good and then
but if she wasn't in a full look it'd be
like why are you putting on like you
yeah you're such like a looking for
sympathy like you really can't win no
you cannot
um but she's being really open with a
lot of the girls which i found shocking
like even had crystal over her house
who's someone
she just met like i know she's super
close with like dorit kyle
and rena so like i would expect her to
have them over at like the biggest
darkest moment in your life she's having
crystal over which i just thought was
interesting like of course she has to
work
but i just found that to be an
interesting factoid and no i thought it
was interesting too she is being really
open but i think still at this point
it's like
it's not as it's not the worst it's
gotten it's not as bad as
it's going to be um i just have like so
many confusing things and
i feel like when that when the articles
came out that like is this a sham
divorce
i don't think i ever thought that it was
but i thought that it could be actually
i didn't i
maybe for a second the timing was just
so peculiar yeah but i guess like the
bigger question is is like
did you know that this stuff was coming
and is that why you left because who
wants to be involved in this
not so you could help him right because
get the [ __ ] away from that
yeah right did she said she saw none of
this coming no she knew
about none of it and i'm just like also
unclear on
what her feelings are about tom like did
she never explicitly said if she thought
tom did this [ __ ] right
she didn't but i feel like she's
implying that he
she thinks he did yes but also like
there's just a few things that are
conflicting because
she talks about how like their marriage
was one thing on the outside and a
totally different thing on the inside
which
you know i can understand but like it
was only that way on the outside because
she spent so much time curating wrapping
that up and like obviously like you
never know what goes on behind closed
doors but like she spent
she went above and beyond to talk about
how wonderful her marriage was to tom
and like
how wonderful he is and what a
supportive partner and like nobody was
asking her to do any of that because
tom's not even really on the show yeah
and so the only reason we thought those
things is because you you made us
you didn't just mention it like you that
was your whole story no you're totally
right
so even in her book that i read like it
was all like
so grateful like really yeah yeah like
there was no
inkling not that there would have been
but like she could have focused more on
herself
right right right no that is really
interesting and honestly
i did feel like the scene where she and
kyle were sitting outside like those
were
real tears like i don't know how you
could but i did think
in her confessional when she was like
crying i was like girl
go to acting classes i don't know i'm so
all the women are standing by her like
that teddy and
rena and kyle were all on a boat in
mexico and they were listening to
expensive and they were like we love you
erica like they are
riding or dying for her because then
sutton said this best like there's still
no facts about what erica
knew or didn't know to me the only like
really damning fact that
i hope gets brought up at some point is
the 20 million dollars from gerardi keys
but i don't think it'll get brought up
because people only found out about it
from the documentary brought up at the
reunion yes you know
so like that's really the the only fact
everything else is kind of conjecture
tom is doing all these things
did you know did you not know you know
tom's whole world was definitely
separate from erica's
but then she also said he was like
declining mentally right
and i think that's also confusing for
people because it's like
the way she talked about her love for
tom like and if she thought she was
gonna be with him till the end and now
he's starting to determine
the end like wouldn't you be with him
now
you're gonna leave this man that like
you love when he's
failing no there are conflicting
messages for sure and i'm really left
feeling like i don't know what to think
but erica is not hiding like she goes on
the girls trip next week and
they sit at dinner and they just talk
about it the whole time so i do think
there's something
that's worth noting like if you have
nothing to hide
if you have something to hide you're not
and you're going through this major
scandal
you're not seeing all of your friends
you're not going on a girl's trip yes
but like her financial situation is
extremely precarious so if i'm her
i'm going every trip i'm making myself
indispensable to this
because when all the lawsuits are said
and done like she's gonna need a job
yeah that's so true
so she's has no she can't not go
what's crazy to me is like literally
this is like another episode where to
read is so irrelevant
beyond like she wasn't she was in one
scene and it was a flashback that she
filmed with uh rena down at her balcony
yeah and they didn't even air it they
just like clipped to it really quickly
it's making me worried for her
i know i'm but i'm just focused on so
many other things so where i stand right
now is i'm still keeping an open mind
still you are you know presumed innocent
until proven guilty so i think
but there's like we're just sort of
waiting yeah
it was confusing i feel like i didn't
get any it was crazy to see her talk
about it and just like finally
acknowledge it because like
we're watching the show now for a month
and we've known all this information and
the show is just catching up so just to
see her even talking about it
is crazy yeah but i got no clarity
nothing tied up like i'm even more
confused i have more questions than
before
yeah but she is talking about it more
than i would have expected
given that it's a legal situation so she
could say i can't answer that again and
she only said it once
and that was when someone asked how did
you find out about the lawsuits
yeah because that's obviously because
also like when did you find out that
these are coming did that she can't
answer that your decision to leave
she can't answer that but i agree she
could have pulled that card a million
more times but
it also could make sense that she found
out about these lawsuits looked at her
husband's like you're a monster i gotta
go
and bounce as fast as it seemed to us
right like she maybe got back from tahoe
and like
saw something and ran right i could see
it play out in a million different ways
and they could all potentially
still pass there is a path to erica's
innocence there is but there's also a
path to
her guilt right so i am just
waiting for more facts with sutton we
love facts
love them um the party like wrapped up
at miranda's at the end of the at the
beginning of the episode between crystal
and sutton
and i'm just like i feel like every time
we come on here i was
i'm like ping-ponging between the two
whose team was i on last week
i don't know because i think i'm on um
sutton's team now
no i'm on team please exclude me from
this narrative yeah um
because it's just sutton needs to i
think sutton is now like making peace
with it
um she needs to let it go like she needs
to move on and like this will just be
like this roadblock between them until
they can find common ground
later on this is just like a little
stubborn like yeah okay i get that you
don't think what you did was wrong like
this woman's crying let's just say sorry
like yeah and even with the manic thing
like she was so choosy about her words
and how she apologized like
even if sutton was acting manic like can
you at least acknowledge like that's a
word that triggers
her like her dad was manic right so she
can't even say i'm sorry
she said i'm sorry that you felt her
like she's just so
she's a wordsmith like she refuses to
give in even in the slightest that like
might acknowledge her doing some sort of
wrong yeah and so in this situation it's
annoying but i do look forward to her
bringing this energy to a worthy
opponent
to a worthy cause like sudden if this
was even a remotely interesting fight
like i would be living for it but it's
so
nonsensical yeah but like
um when wherever her next conflict
arises i just hope it's with someone
who's like
you know just who we want to fight with
yeah exactly also i was reading like on
twitter and everyone's just like you
know
uh they were so like uh rina
erica all these women were so quick like
oh darice hooked up with brandy we're
gonna believe that yeah we're gonna you
know
it's hard not to bring it back to the
denise thing and then
like there's these crazy legal rumors
about erica and they completely stand by
her
no i know and at first i was like okay
you guys we can't bring everything back
to nobody
but then i was like denise got like her
life ruined
for for hooking up with randy glanville
like
not a crime not a crime nothing wrong
with it her personal business yeah
erica is stands accused of atrocities
and it's like well we don't have all the
facts right right no it's so it's so
hypocritical
yeah especially from rena like just
and i i actually if erica was my friend
i would do the same thing like i would
say
denise was her friend like yeah it's
actually and i don't want to be that
person who like always brings it back to
denise but it's worth
mentioning because we got no justice
yeah no but i hope angie brings that up
yeah i do think that you know if you are
erica's friend and you like love and
adore erica
and think she's a good person like that
is that's what you do that's what
friends of course
so these women are true friends but the
thing about denise is like even if you
found out it was true or not it's not
about denise being a good person like
yeah it's just no no agreed it's just so
frustrating it's so frustrating
um so that's that on that tomorrow
let's wrap up love island i didn't watch
last night but i'm gonna watch last
night's end tonight and then we'll talk
about it tomorrow sounds good
i will join you catch up on love island
with us and we'll be recapping it
tomorrow for friday's show it's friday
it's so close we're so close you guys
could smell it so
that's all she wrote thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories
that you yes you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning no
sorry i [ __ ] it up it's okay take it
from the top
believe in yourself you got this thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast the monday morning show where we
deal with the fast side stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toes no
i keep getting caught in the same
trouble okay that you need to know every
monday
friday thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast the millennium
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public video i
have radio cast box all the places so
whenever you listen to the podcast five
nights morning show sleeping five star
view about a beautiful setting and smart
we are you know what's nice is that
once we start the outro people probably
turn off the episodes so they don't even
know that i [ __ ] it up twice
right that's true and we should also say
something crazy right now so only like
the people who stay till the end know
yeah okay but you guys if you hear this
leave a comment on our instagram
with um with with
the matcha emoji and just like we'll
have our own like a little secret and
that one will know
matcha but we can't make this too long
because then people will keep
you